invité de turbo d'émission sur m6
florent pagny expliqué ouvertement avoir
du vent il ya quelques années sa
collection de voitures pour payer ses
impôts il ajoute sa phrase que j'adore
qui est faut se poser les bonnes
questions
voilà donc une sortie bien politiquement
incorrect qui illustre parfaitement le
tempérament du chanteur et on s'est posé
la question est ce qu'il existe encore
des gens qui sont politiquement
incorrect est ce que le politiquement
correct ça fait une carrière aujourd'hui
en 2019 ou au contraire ça là bim regard
des sujets on en parle après huit mois
quand on a une voiture comme ça pourquoi
en avant bon la venturi ghosn
j'ai vendu sa java toute une collection
et j'ai tout vendu parce que les uns
pour arriver et bim florent pagny cette
semaine fidèle à lui-même démarre au
quart de tour dès qu'il s'agit de
balancer sur les impôts
saint nazaire y associe les stars
politiquement incorrect peuvent faire de
la provoc comme depardieu qui explique
que vladimir poutine lui donne des cours
de géopolitique où les stars peuvent
parler cash grâce que c'est dans leur
nature comme d'autres miss france j'aime
manger j'aime rigoler par l'effort et
dormir et je vais continuer à être comme
ça que vous le vouliez ou non
alors bon courage parce que vous avez
encore neuf mois à me supporter ne
supporte pas il m'a la mare
et m parce que justement tu es tout sauf
un
[Musique]
et bizarrement les stars qui raconte ou
font n'importe quoi sont souvent
pardonné par le public
quelquefois on en redemande même kanye
west sur connerie sur connerie problème
on continue kate moss filmer le nez dans
la coque
elle choque encore plus de contrats
publicitaires mel gibson tient des
propos homophobe misogyne antisémites et
auraient tabassé sa femme ça c'est
mauvais pour ma libération
conditionnelle salle n'a pas empêché
d'être nommé meilleur réalisateur aux
oscars dix ans plus tard alors être
cache un frein ou un booster de carrière
voilà un frère un booster c'est un frein
et guillaume pour vous pourquoi
aujourd'hui 2019 citez moi un jeune
aujourd'hui qui dit vraiment ce qu'ils
pensent moi la cité ment à ce qu'est ou
leur gueule c'est ma génération c'est à
dire en gros oui sarde en voilà assez
large de maman aujourd'hui on ne peut
plus rien dire
la période est aux lys ou au consensus
vous ouvrez votre gueule vous fait
défoncer qualif on s'est défoncé vous ne
pouvez plus rien dire c'est très triste
c'est très dommage mais je pense que on
est dans une société d'hypocrites où on
dit tout va bien une société de robinet
d'eau tiède et en fait dans la réalité
est ce que la question du concours seb
est ce que tu penses être que si à
florent pagny avait dit au début de sa
carrière tout ce qu'il dit aujourd'hui
sur les impôts et tout ça parce
qu'aujourd'hui il se lâche tous quand
ils ont 55 ans en fin de carrière mais
ce que s'il avait dit au début quand on
dépend du sujet quand c'est les impôts
tout le monde est d'accord avec lui
parce que personnellement je payer des
impôts moi ça me choque ce qu'il dit sur
les impôts savez l'argent je suis désolé
des artistes comme lui ils se font
assassiner par les impôts mais sa
mission lui mais en général c'est
l'inversé la télévision on nous dit la
même chose à la télévision on est tous
pardon de gauche ou le demandent quand
on reçoit le eux de dire qu'on est
content de payer des impôts de
participer à la france et même de dire
j'en ai entendu dire quand je ressors
mon tir d'impôts je suis heureux il faut
dire ça l'antenne si on dit ça vendus
dans payer parce que j'ai une grosse
bagnole en plein jt je n'ai tourné
massacrés non mais
il peut le dire sans avoir trop de
problèmes façon il ya déjà eu des
sorties sur les impôts je sais pas si
vous rappeler mais quand il avait sorti
presse qui roule bocage où il s'était
mis à dos la presse et il avait eu des
problèmes pendant de nombreuses années
et dans les médias qu on voit mel gibson
mois mel gibson le jour où c'est arrivé
à malibu j étais j'étais à la sortie du
commissariat
il peut vous garantir que pendant 7 8
ans l'a pas vu c'est vrai alors que
c'était un monstre du cinéma
hollywoodien s'élevait à cuesmes freiner
sa quête qui l'avait fait c'était très
grave bah il s'était fait arrêter par
des policiers il y en avait inquiété
noir il l'avait traité de salut c'était
pensant qu'ils allaient s'en sortir
parce que la police de malibu
normalement on fait un chèque qu'on s'en
sort mais là il y en a un qui a parlé
etc mais même lui qui était très haut
placée à hollywood a quand même eu des
problèmes si on parle d'un dieudonné ou
d'une véronique genest qui ont des
sorties danse marionnettes elle cartonne
au théâtre aujourd'hui elle va
retravailler zones de rucks a quand même
ça ça lui fera de leur carrière
dieudonné salle à freiner tout dépend de
ce qu'il dit si c'est les impôts je
pense que ça va moins choqué quand elle
sortira six ans mais là on change on
alors donc vous êtes effectivement n'a
de ce côté là de mandat quand tu parles
quand vous parlez de mel gibson et c'est
quand on est homophobe race et dexter a
fait des listes est pas politiquement
incorrect fait on dit n'importe quoi on
dit on fait des lilas frappe et affamés
tout ça d'aucuns me kate moss ce qui
prend d'être époque là interdite c'est
un délit c'est pas bien et c'est pas
comme ça qu'elle va essayer de faire
plein de contre à l'époque parce que
fort heureusement mais pas associer son
image à quelqu'un qui ait fait des
délits après des gens qui parlent pour
dire je suis riche je suis content de
l'être le sting qui a encore dit la
semaine dernière moi j'ai des baskets et
matisse dans mon salon je trouve ça
super et oui je suis vaniteux et tant
mieux
les gens l'adorent kms qui chante bien
et c'est pas grave hein comme florent
pagny d'ailleurs qui voit là la presse
je leur crache dessus c'est des connards
c'est bien beau mais aussi le crack dieu
qu'ils ont tous à sa rivale arrivera
aujourd'hui en disant mais ça ne me suis
acheté un picasso grâce à mon bukavu
grâce à mon moment disons qu'un jeune ne
le dit ont bondi ce que tu es sûr que le
françois et pensent qu'il ferait une
carrière derrière nous aujourd'hui sera
arrêté web est le corps et la pale ale
il a quand même le succès il montre ses
maisons etc
on voit qu'il a une voix m2 milliardaire
enfin demain mais aux états unis sa case
horaire par will you are états unis
affichent en effet pas genre j'ai rien
du tout et je roule en deux chevaux
rachel instruments et catherine h et
pour toi c'est un frein oui c'est un
prince que forcément on prend position
donc on se met forcément une partie du
public ado moi je sais que quand on est
miss france contrairement à vaima lama
qui a décidé de faire comme elle
l'entend
et à la raison ben tu vois que ça marche
plutôt bien mais du coup moi je me
souviens qu'à mon époque on nous avait
dit surtout quand il ya des questions de
politique de religion
voilà des choses assez punchy voilà vous
avez marre de training pour savoir quoi
répondre à ces questions là bas on nous
dit botté en touche en fait tenté à
chaque fois il faut pas prendre position
c'était vraiment à chaque fois que je
faisais une émission télé un peu à
ardisson et on me préparer là sauf au
sourire et faut sourire était partie
sonnée tout le contraire je pense que
c'est un booster de carrière parce que
justement comme des guillemets sont
tellement tous politiquement correct que
se pose un peu l'ouvrir parler un peu
cash est cassée pas transgressif c'est
pas dire oh je suis raciste homophobe en
rien par les cash
eh bien on ce qu'on sort du lot et à des
gens comme mathilde seigner or certes
150 ans la raison non mais regardez
daniel balavoine que faire à titre
personnel quelqu'un qui par le cash même
si je sais pas d'accord avec lui on
serait discours politiquement correct
mais bienveillant qui sont complètement
fait cas mais mathilde seigner sac a été
boostée camp a été boosté à des
déclarations jugées aurait dit rires
est-ce qu'on peut passer juste un avant
centre di mille sujets vous avez tout de
parler juste des déclaré mathilde
seigner qu'elle ne peut plus rien dire
et qu'on est on la voit beaucoup moins
la télévision pour cette raison là alors
un film qui va kaki starmania qui va
cartonner